Top score.
Would you want a video podcast as well?
We'll do a video blog.
Oh,
after we interview people.
When I talk,
yes.
How was your experience with the podcast?
You get to lift those country Melder people know what the fuck is up.
Good aboriginal joke just to Jackson.
That's a,
yeah.
No,
they were great man.
They're sent there.
They were sensitive about it,
but it's festival people though,
right?
Once you go back to conquering hero,
they'll forget about all that.
You'll have a 10 minute aboriginal baby chunk open right over with that.
Yeah.
Just something again,
something.
Did you let it go?
And I look on Australia,
but the trip is,
the flight is horrifying.
Terrible your body too,
right?
I'm still not over the return.
Really?
Dude,
I'm waking up at seven 30 and eight you last time I got up at seven get a job.
Probably like,
yeah,
I mean it's,
it's,
I've never,
I'm home a week now.
And what time you usually go to bed?
I usually go to bed like around one is probably what time you wake up.
If I do that on a normal thing,
it would,
I would be up at like 10 or 10 30 normal.
If I,
if I go to bed at one it's a nice and leisurely.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Comedy style,
comedy style bitches.
Just their reason for alarm clocks.
Yeah.
Well I knew if we catch flights,
that's the only time I get up for shit.
That and radio.
Do you write your best stuff at night?
Do you write at night?
Yeah.
Yeah,
me too.
What is that about?
Why is it?
I don't know,
but I can't do mornings,
man.
I know.
I try and I've tried to,
I get up in the morning,
I'll have a cup of coffee and just start writing.
Sometimes I,
sometimes I can edit things in the morning because my talent,
my and impatient.
So sometimes like man,
too wordy.
I'm good at editing things.
Yeah.
Cause I want to cut to the quick,
you know,
I just can't,
I find sometimes I'm like whatever,
some thoughts and boost of inspiration after I've laid down,
I'll lay down.
So I'm thinking about something.
It wasn't going to sleep.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
And I get up and start writing.
I made myself get up to,
or I have a,
I'm,
I keep my phone right by the bed alarms on my phone.
Oh,
there.
And I have the little voice notes.
I'll just make a little voice note of it.
Yeah.
That's a good,
that's a good way to do it.
Actually,
I started using the voice note thing.
I was a little crazy to fantasy wine tasting thing,
man.
Tell him stuff.
It was great.
A lot of wine tastings,
romantic,
romantic.
But the only weird thing is like the whole city is based on wine.
So everyone's ever getting wasted and drunk and it's all couples.
But at 10 o'clock it's a ghost town.
So we want,
would you want swingers clubs?
I thought there'd be like,
you know,
people hanging out on the street.
No,
not one car.
Not One person.
Every hotel though.
No vacancy.
So it was packed with people,
but everyone's just passed out by eight o'clock.
So what part of the country was his Sylvain California.
It's a north.
About 40 minutes north of Santa Barbara and ate mushrooms instead.
We ate mushrooms.
Yeah.
And did you learn anything while you're eating mushrooms?
Yeah,
antique hotels are very scary.
I'm not sure.
It just feels scary.
Spooky like old wallpaper and old like
stuff everywhere.
It's just memories in that stuff.
Yeah.
This guy named Rupert Sheldrake and thinks that there's memory and everything.
It seemed like that in your own town,
Brian.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I love Joe because Joe just like me stoned.
Really think about it like it's like me if I ate a handful of mushrooms,
right?
Like,
like,
you know,
Dr Grew and I talked about this many times.
You like ideas and I love people that like ideas.
Not so much.
Jokes are not so much,
you know,
catch phrases,
but I DHEAS and uh,
you Dick Ideas.
I do.
Thanks man.
Thanks for being [inaudible] and gentlemen.
That's right.
Glitches.
I get the a list here.
I don't come in a long running tradition of people leaving shit behind on the
podcast.
Adam Corolla has left behind his glasses.
Oh my goodness.
Adam,
I have your fucking glasses.
I also have nick Swardson's sweater.
Um,
I had bill burrs comb for the longest time,
so we gave it back to Belvoir.
And what else did we get?
A magical leavers iPhone here.
Oh,
his iPad.
And I got him back to his IPAD.
That was the one we should have kept the most.
I got your glasses,
John Heffrons in the motherfucking house.
A half from when you're doing these days.
What's going on in the squares?
Uh,
you know,
neuro linguistic programming,
reading psychology books,
right?
Technology boats,
Raymond scripts.
What does technology look around again,
a cognitive therapy and standup comedy.
How did not take,
so how to find the humor,
the crappiest thing that staff needs to do that.
Interesting.
Do you think that sometimes you will sabotage your life just to create more
material?
Not Possible.
I think,
uh,
I think it helps because nobody,
nobody wants to hear comic.
When he got on stage going,
wow,
traffic was awesome getting here and made it right to,
man,
I have a lot of money.
Boy Am I in shape.
I went to vacation with my wife,
everything was awesome.
That's a boring show.
So you have to be every year that's conflict and paste that on top of top of the
actual conflict and painted life would normally give.
Do you think you create some just for material or did you take that you just so
happened to be lucky in that you're blessed with a fucked up chaotic life that
lends itself to a good comment.
I say that you probably create more than anything you create more than any
therapy world is exactly how you want it to be.
That's right.
Yes.
This is like the secret we're giving you like two minutes.
We explain the power of positive thinking,
the law of attraction.
All right.
Yeah.
Oh.